the met police investigation into
breaches of the coronavirus regulations
at downing street in whitehall has
concluded today and in total we've made
126 referrals for a fixed penalty notice
to be issued
some of those referrals were for more
than one
fixed party notice to be issued 28
people
have been referred for between two and
five fixed penalty notices so just
because 28 people
had between two and five
so repeat offenders effectively
28 people had between two and five
referrals yes okay assistant
commissioner you've you just said you've
issued 126
fines to lawmakers today
that's the highest number of fines
issued to one collective group of people
how historic is this moment is it a
precedent set
and do you find it shocking
i think the the whole of the pandemic
was
extraordinary times wasn't it
and many things happened that haven't
happened before and
haven't happened since
we've carried out a really thorough
painstaking and impartial investigation
into what went
into what happened
uh that's the right thing for us to have
done and as i've said that has concluded
today uh with the outcome that i've
described do you find it shocking though
that lawmakers are having
this number of fines
i think the thing for me to to comment
on is the work that we have done
we
knew that in to open an investigation
certain criteria needed to be met in our
view
that would mean that the people involved
knew or ought to have known
that what they were doing was a breach
that if we didn't investigate it would
undermine the legitimacy of the law
and that there was probably no
reasonable defense in place so those
criteria we applied and that's what led
us to start the investigation that we
did
that we did start
and today that investigation has
concluded we knew that we needed to see
strong evidence if we were going to
issue
a fixed penalty notice and we have seen
that in 126 cases so what you've seen in
126 quarters of people that knew or
should have known that this was breaking
the law when to head anywhere
effectively well to issue an fpn
uh you would need strong evidence that
a breach had occurred
the criteria about that i just described
relate to opening the investigation at
the start
an assistant commissioner your criteria
for launching the investigation as you
said was that not doing so would
significantly undermine the legitimacy
of the law
in your eyes issuing these fines to
those people who made the laws
in itself has undermined the legitimacy
of those laws do you agree with that
that's not for me to comment on the
things that i
am here to tell you about is the
how we went about our investigation
uh and the conclusions that we have
reached
were you surprised about the level of
fixed penalty notices given that these
people did write the laws because i i
was surprised are you
i think a number of people members of
the public have been both surprised and
concerned
uh what they have heard and i'm sure
they will be surprised and concerned
about the outcome of our investigation
but we followed of you know a very
thorough impartial investigation
we've looked at over 1 000 documents
which included a whole range of
different material
and we've carried out a very careful
assessment process and that's reached
the conclusions that it's reached and
assistant chris you said at the
beginning that these were extraordinary
times the pandemic an unprecedented
situation and we've ended up in this
place have you ever done anything like
this before in terms of an investigation
that
has hit so closely on the people that
actually make laws
we have carried out various
investigations in the past into all
sorts of different people and the
metropolitan police like all police
services will always
uh if we're called on we'll always do
those sorts of investigations and we'll
do them impartially and just finally the
investigation has cost 460 000 pounds at
a time when the country's heading into
recession and resources not at least the
mets are significantly stretched are you
concerned with the impression that will
give to the public this use of public
money to investigate this
well as i've said i think the public
were very concerned about what they had
seen and i think they i know that they
wanted that to be investigated
in order to carry out the investigation
with the thoroughness that that was
right
those are the costs that have been um
incurred
that includes the costs of a full-time
team of 12
both their normal costs and their
overtime
various support that was given into the
investigation and those involved in the
assessment processes so it covers quite
a wide range of activity and just
finally as a senior police officer in
this country you talked about people
being concerned about what they'd seen
were you personally concerned about what
you uncovered
as i've said i know that there was a
great deal of public concern about this
it is my role and my office's role to
carry out that investigation and to do
so impartially and that's what we've
done and just one more thing was
everyone cooperative fully cooperative
yes they were okay thank you so much
thank you assistant commissioner thank
you